uh
thank you
staying for the last session uh so and
also uh thanks for bark uh that for
doing my job much easier for me because
a lot of the discussions that I wanted
to do actually were done which is great
you can do them again it was so much fun
so now I'm going to talk about the uh
the conversation the hardness needed for
Crown from crypto which has been the
topic of a lot of today uh and if joints
worked with trica and the one who's
going to talk right after me and I'll
give much more information but anyway so
is you know I'm sure you haven't seen
this picture in a while so uh at least
an hour so uh to hear this again uh uh
you know one refunctions you know what a
beautiful concept beautiful drawing uh
and uh you know we think of a minimum uh
primitive for a confession cryptography
and you know so it was funny to listen
to to Mark talk this morning it's
actually kind of reviewing the arguments
we were having among the three of us as
we were writing the introduction you
know the results were there but actually
writing and explaining why it's
important by this like you know involved
a lot of discussion about us which
really brought up a lot of the the
issues that Mark talked about was really
interesting to see it uh so so what are
what why why the folks so wonderful so
you know so it's a simple form tangible
form of uh you know potential hardness
uh with some minimal structure and uh
you know it's sufficient for much of
cryptography and uh it's necessary for
for almost all computational
cryptography which is whatever we cannot
be doing cannot be done I guess or
potentially unboxed adversaries
and uh and it's also of course used for
this as a hub for implications if you
have you know garbling for any function
you can drop link for all functions and
etc etc just going through one way and
it's kind of another really important
property I think uh is that it's
naturally amplifiable can I give you a
path to how you can get hardness from
from rocks from nothing you know there's
a big one function unfortunately cannot
be two weeks can be you know only
slightly week and then you can amplify
Etc so so it's a nice concept that we
like it and uh
and I don't know why you know the
question is why do we actually uh talk
about one function as opposed to prgs or
something else is the minimal assumption
and you know maybe just historical that
you know it was it talked about in in by
doing you know uh in 76 and it actually
took a lot of effort to get prgs for one
of the functions you know but they also
think there's something to it that you
know for instance this natural
amplifiability doesn't really work for
prgs you know even to get one bit of prg
you know there's also a high order
already and it's not pretty clear what
it means be weaker than that in a
natural way for prgs and for one
function you can and again we have all
those beautiful pictures and all those
Primitives that are already equivalent
to one of the functions and don't just
implied by one functions uh um maybe one
they will be equivalent to and and
moreover we have this dichotomy for
Primitives uh um and notice by way that
I'm not talking I'm trying very hard
throughout the talk and not use the word
assumptions because uh it's really I
don't know something strange but it's a
primitive right the potential hardness
it's a property whether you assume it to
use it and you know that's different so
try not to use assumptions so so so so
so but anyway so so what are those uh
what is it the economy that by now we
all know so uh uh so there are all these
things that we could do from against
potentially unbounded adversaries
information theoretic cryptography we
like to call it and they're all these uh
stuff that we uh that that computational
which everything as I said almost
everything uh is implied by one
functions so there are some Renegades
there's this IO that it's not clear and
there's you know weekly verifiable
puzzles that are useful or captures
whatever well maybe captures if useful
anymore or not it's questionable but
whatever the the uh so the the
mathematical process is interesting and
anyway every thing that you know to do
that is not that is you know
computational crypto is always needs
three is not equal to NP and so so we we
thought we think
so uh
so the this is uh uh you know the State
of the State of the world but then you
know uh come uh Quantum information
processing
um
yes what's the the right two columns
what is it what are the difference
between the right ones and uh so so
this is functions is everything that is
incredible ones
that uh those uh uh those parts of the
puzzles that you can you know verify
when you generate but uh but you cannot
verify well in your own if you just says
thank you
so
[Laughter]
anyway so come quite some information
processing that's what it is so so uh uh
so uh the information is organized in
this uh strange thing called qubits
right that what are these stupids you
know you know people gonna you know no
one really cringes where they talk about
this way but anyway so I see now these
are semi obfuscated uh randomized boxes
right so it's this information is
organizing those or is those you know
things called qubits and there's a lot
of information in the qubit but you
cannot really uh access all of it you
can only access in certain ways you know
you can just read it you actually have
to measure and you know whatever and uh
and it cannot be cloned but thank you
also manipulate information in the qubit
directly now thinking it as uh uh it's
kind of nice to you but inside there is
a lot of liquid inside lots of things
going on but as soon as you break it you
lose a lot of information I don't know
uh um and you can also cause these
keywords to interact with each other the
liquid inside the cubic entanglement
right and information gets shared among
many qubits in via the states and and
whenever you uh you do you can do local
qubit manipulation but they affect
global effect on the state uh um anyway
this is just a high level you know a
personal view of this string thing uh um
and still information can be
accessed only partially by the way it's
a new model of computation uh whatever
that that is and it is a brand new all
this you know so uh you know we can you
know you know we can do uh key exchange
against you know computationally
unbounded adversaries now this already
becomes uh uh uh uh information Theory
crypto uh so maybe you know okay if you
can can all of crypto could be
information theoretical you know the
third and then there was factoring some
ad
all heart problems can be solved with
Quantum information positive way again
we know that's not so uh and and in
particular there are cryptographic tasks
that are still impossible against
competition about their other things
right so so that's maybe the point is
that forget assumptions not assumptions
there are those tasks that we can only
do against computationally bounded
Quantum other search right uh but still
this is a a very different world in the
sense that uh now for instance we can
actually uh construct
OT NPC uh directly from one with
functions as we know you know we know
that in in a black box way you know
classically we cannot do it
um and uh in fact you know as we
discussed we'll discussed several times
today that actually we could do all
those commitment of Lewis transfer NPC
all those things even without one
refunctions uh um using this notion of
quantum around this that that suffice
this and this Quantum surroundings
doesn't apply one of the functions at
all uh or does not seem to imply a lot
um so uh so one of those you know again
I'm just looking quickly uh not try to
not repeat too much uh but just the
point I want to say that this sort of
State generator that uh that Mark was
talking about
um so it's really indistinguishable you
know it's very kind of superficially it
looks very similar to the definition of
prg
um but uh but this is really something
which is purely a Quantum surroundings
in what sense what I mean by that that
if you only think about your classical
distinguishers how what does it mean to
have a classical distinguisher you know
for a Quantum State the meaning of the
distinguisher can only do the naive
thing that you know measure it in the
standard basis and then do computational
what you get if this is the only thing
you can do that uh
PRS is Trivial you can just do it
against obviously unbounded other things
right
you could just do a
I mean just you know whatever it is the
gender of K you just apply a Heidelberg
okay and that's it of course you get a
state which is when you measure it you
get a complete uniform string so uh
um so so this is a kind of like uh uh it
looks like a prg but it's something very
different in a sense it's something
that's meaningful or there's some
hardness that can be extracted only by
uh uh uh meaningful Quantum information
processing uh and we know that it's not
really hard to postpone it's not clear
how to construct one it functions from
PRS thread generators spsgs and in
particular we know they cannot work in a
black box
and still can be used to do all those
great things
um great so so maybe uh
okay so now the last question are the
minimals for python crypto uh um and can
we build psgs from all those things from
Quantum commitments uh um so how would
we do it right so classically how do we
you know uh construct your Jesus
yeah
even commitments to classical bits but
just Quantum commitments
yeah yeah and it could make me a Quantum
commitment for uh uh a classical bit
it's something that we know to do from
those surround States right right
and so let me go the other way right
because you know now you have a point of
commitment right and you want to to
build the PRC like like we do in crypto
In classical crypto right so so how do
you do it in classically you have a
community
you take all these guys you did the work
for us and you know whatever uh uh
healing stuff so but uh so that's what
we do classically you know only
condition to do it but how to do it
quantly it's not clear right so there's
this one by state generators that uh
that again Mark was talking about in the
morning uh uh it doesn't seem to to help
right uh and uh and and in particular
the the issue is that in the quantum
world this uh distinguishing to
inversion to the the deciding to to
search doesn't really work in the way
that we'd like it to work it will not
get into details here but uh it really
doesn't work right so so so those things
not clear it's not clear what's going on
so so again so let's go back to this uh
picture of the world uh uh in the
quantum world so we have all those
Primitives from before that the
information theoretically secure they
still are now we have key exchange there
um and we still have one of the
functions here uh uh but now we have all
this all of crypto most of crypto is now
sitting here you can do it from this
certain extent generators which are
incredible functions we know where they
are you know so uh IO may be still there
but we don't know where these are so so
the question is like what would be a
minimum assumption is there a natural
minimal uh uh not assumption primitive
for quality of scripture what would be
best is the what would you take the the
role of 400 function uh uh for Quantum
crypto
so
let's go back to the uh into the origins
maybe and and uh let's look at something
that you know was kind of like not
really look but you know it was looked
at but you know it wasn't really uh uh
got a lot of attention is this notion
that ordered put up many years ago I
think it was exactly there was a short
period of time between uh you know we
didn't really know how to do yet the
prgs for when we function so it was
still uh not completely trivial uh but
it is a meaningful a notion in of itself
so so do you really need prgs to get
like a meaningful indistinguishability
based uh notion or or distinguishing
based notion of uh for crypto so uh so
that came up with this uh uh notion of
pairs of of uh distribution generators
uh uh g0 and G1 that uh they have these
properties they were efficiently
generatable uh uh and there are
statistically far with this solution
that you get when you uh run you know
them on random inputs uh is close to one
and there are computationally
distinguishable in a sense that you know
again the distribution that you get but
applying those two circuits on on random
inputs are in distinguishable right and
and it turns out that it's a equivalent
to one the functions that's what uh of
the shows
um and uh but also kind of it really
feels natural you can actually get a lot
of Primitives from it in a very natural
way classically
um so it's nice and also you know again
people haven't really looked at it but
it's kind of like naturally amplifiable
in a way that um a lot like sort of like
one way functions and unlike prgs right
to think about what happens with you
know the statistical distance has been
not one and the the computational
distance is not negligible but still
there is a gap and you can you know
amplify so so it looks nice so uh
for any amount of non-trivial Gap
they're all the same no no well there's
uh I know I don't think there's a proof
written anywhere I'm just saying that uh
you know but you need to help it's a bit
like the uh this polarization thing of
facility
we need the uh
any Gap we don't care where where it is
though yeah we just need to be
sufficient whatever some constant which
is sufficiently locked up
uh
so so
again so
now let's open so now let's generate to
the point now this is something that you
can naturally generalize think of how to
generalize it so now we kind of think of
uh uh two uh uh
um circuits and they're going to be uh
Quantum circuits and classical
description of quantum circus and uh
there are two different uh you know
circuits that they can output uh you
know any arbitrary mixed state of
distribution over pure State uh and we
think of the whatever the output has two
parts there is an alpha and a beta right
uh for each one of them uh you can think
of the the beta is whatever we you know
classically would be the state or
whatever the the intermediate
computation that we don't we throw away
classically here we cannot throw it so
we just put it on the side uh and uh so
again to those uh uh uh two sectors are
going to be we want the business is
really far now in Trace distance just on
the alphas which of the outputs the
trace distance uh of the state should be
uh close to one uh and notice that now I
I don't give it Randomness I just filled
it with the zeros because it can
generate all the relevance itself so
essentially if you just the the quantum
computation is deterministic the
computation there is no Randomness on
the Facebook on the outside not
necessarily
um
and again all the residents is is in is
inside the ice cubes in in the states
right and um and and still there are
computationally indistinguishable the uh
the the the outputs
um so actually uh sorry that should be
just the uh the alpha should be confused
the distinguishable
um not not everything
um and and that's it so so we want those
uh uh these are the properties and let's
see what we can get from this right so
this is the the quantum monologue of the
uh of The Goldberg uh uh person
distributions so yeah
yes
the upper registered yes so you know
there's also the better but I'm not
talking about them they I'm just the
requirement is only on the office
yeah
and it's important it's a typo here that
also the outstarts should be
distinguishable right sure so the best
as I'm not talking about now yeah the
beta is like the hidden Randomness yeah
so and so if you've had it yeah
yeah is it equivalent to allow the G's
to measure
the pressure or the new measurements on
the state yeah that's equivalent to
having a beta uh sure but you can have a
juice measure about uh you know you can
always think of you know what would
happen if you didn't measure
that's the purpose that's kind of the
purpose of the betas right yes like we
just want to look at what would happen
if we measured but you see the minute
that actually it's very important I will
use it without measuring is better so
okay awesome but but yes yeah you can
think of it this way if you just measure
the bear doesn't throw them out and then
you just
and as you know in Quantum you know
measuring and putting that aside is the
same thing so yeah
okay
um okay
so
um
so so let's see what we have you know
just what we could say Tubidy or or in
simple observations about the you know
how efi's affair with the rest of the
world so uh uh so first you know those
the classical version The Goldberg
version our special case of of the
quantum one just uh uh uh you know if we
just think of uh add this uh how the
market level of other mods uh uh before
the you know the applying the the
circuit right just to create Randomness
just to be reciprocity
um so so that's my thing and also PRT is
a special case of efis because there are
more structures definitely uh uh uh give
you uh surroundings
um
sir the first would not be the other way
around
oh sorry Miss red and it's ready
okay so and and the important part is
that in if you're a students you know so
so let me finds the quantum Randomness
cannot be taken apart from the uh the
circuit also penalty programmed they're
kind of all inside the SQ so you know
what when you do the computation from
the outside you don't see it
um so it in the same way yes PSG the
efis do not seem to imply uh either one
of the functions or even once by state
generators uh which is the kind of the
quantum uh Quantum one natural
counterpart Quantum counterpart of one
Reflections and the you know the correct
smear separation
nice uh the black book's great
um you know so there's a question
obviously how do we construct them so
stay tuned for that I'll say a word
about it and it don't say a lot more
about it uh uh but uh but let's see how
EFI you know uh uh how it fares that's
kind of like a candidate minimal
assumption for Quantum crypto yeah there
was like a bit of a change though like
like the the Gap though that doesn't
matter classic Place matters here right
yeah
one now between computational
statistical so that's a great question
so yeah so so it's actually it's a great
question can you amplify EFI so if you
start
I I want to hope that you can right so
so there is a great hope that you
actually get exactly the same parameters
classically if you start from year five
from any Alpha and beta that are the
right things
as of the right now unless you're Luanne
you don't know how to do it
that's what yeah but I don't know even
if you're not sure you can do it
uh this conjunction no it's a great
question yeah
you want to uh commit no no no no no
it's okay
so so
um
okay so so
let's see so so we know that certain you
know so we show how E5 fair so so
friends with EFI we already know that we
do commitments somebody with transfer
multiple competition we show that you
add to the bunch you could do a Quantum
computational journals fall off the uip
um
and also it is implied by
yeah commitments uh uh is semi honest of
t uh um they could be talking about a
minimal version of all of these above
any you know people NPC I'll talk about
it more but any PC for non-trivial
function and any non-trivial even
honestly a fire uh Quantum zero
knowledge so it's a so the same way that
one of the functions is for the
classical setting EFI is not everything
so there is a encryption and pure
students they imply EFI we don't know if
anything back
um and there are things like one to
money that we don't know any any uh uh
in any direction a public Heat by the
money
um so let me show a little bit of the uh
of the uh of those uh implications right
so that you spend time on it how much
time do I have
okay so so
um so so Quantum bits commitment so
we've seen this several times the same
box actually appeared in the morning
several times you know you know this box
is working overtime so we want the
commitment and uh the commit phase and
they have the the information that you
actually give in the review phase and we
want the uh the uh the receiver to uh uh
to be able to open when we give him the
key and what we want is uh is the hiding
is that you know uh um even when the
receiver is malicious you know they and
until we give it the key they uh uh he
doesn't know the message and the bad
thing is that you know you can you know
the uh
is that you can only open the same
recipe even against the malicious uh
committer and I'm not talking about
Quantum uh pizza right just classical
bits but
so as what we know
um you know that it's really nice uh uh
approve observation by by Young that
also uh Fermi mentioned earlier that you
know without causing generality in
Quantum commitments uh it's uh uh it's
uh it's enough to assume that you know
to build commitments against an honest
committer but I mean honest that it
actually follows the protocol uh uh
except maybe not forgetting or not
measuring but it's supposed to measure
right so uh you know it's enough to do
that so so uh so that's so that's nice
um so let's see anyway how to do
Bitcoins from EFI just like uh uh uh
that the first thing which is uh almost
immediate so uh uh so how would you uh
commit so you have an EFI so uh uh so
you just you know you just run GB
reviews the beat you want to commit
right and you get this Alpha and uh and
then the opening is going to be the
better it exactly that state that you
didn't send before and you could have
measured or you put aside now you need
it for the opening this this is the
opening and then you will how do you
verify you just the uh the receiver
sdr44 now he has the beta now you can
actually run GB in reverse and see that
it measures at the end and see that you
get zero sorry and because uh Trace
distance is large you know if if it you
know you can achieve
okay so that's a very simple kind of
canonical uh
okay uh so
so okay it's a statistically binding
because of uh uh because of the stress
distance and it's in its competition
behind it
and uh so now from here we uh you can
get also statistical binding like
negligible or is it because of Trace
distance would they not have to be that
large or anything
well the first distance uh well the way
they find it it was just one right so so
like but just to make it good but if you
want it to be smaller then you should
amplify okay
uh yeah
um
okay so because so
um okay so one one thing that you can do
here from now we have statistically
binding and and potentially hiding
commitment you can actually flip things
you know there are several different uh
uh complementary ways to do this
actually it's very cute tricks but now
you can guess statistically hiding and
computationally binding commitments in
the same in in in in in a number of
different ways
um you can also get a stronger notion
which spots relatable you know provocal
extractable commitments uh um this is
done by a a Qi and then you can actually
use them to do uh NPC
um uh in in in in generic ways
um
okay so uh so we know we can do
commitments from efis how do we get e5s
from right
um so if you have statistically uh uh
binding commitments uh then the already
uh know the immunity to get an EFI
because uh the canonical form commitment
um
so uh but but how do we how do we get
from General commitments right so so we
have a commitment now that is neither
statistically binding not statistically
hardly interpretation in both ways and
now we want to get a near five of it
right and EFI has a statistical you know
requirement there so how do we do that
uh so the hiding of the commitment will
give you distinguishability seems uh
easy and but now we have only compress
National binding how do we get a
statistical distance right so that's a
uh that's kind of seemed a bit less
clear so so how do we do it so the main
idea is uh to go uh via you know
previous transfer and why I believe was
transferred because uh Wheels transfer
is a primitive that both you know both
sides you know uh the the requirements
is about the distinctionability uh uh so
uh so it seems like uh an easier thing
to work with and we show that it does
work
um so what
we're going to build EFI uh so let's do
it
um so so what's oblivious answer I just
remind you so
um it's a few minutes to forget from the
morning so so uh the the ascendants two
bits the uh they receive a choice bit
and he gets the appropriate a bit from
the sender
um and the semi under security means
that you know during the part of
execution everybody is honest except for
purification what are these
verifications well the Cinematic but
it's essentially that you know parties
don't forget you tell it to measure to
erase they don't do it because they
whatever peer refer uh uh so uh so this
is our notion of some yeah security you
can think of other ones but this is what
works for us uh so
um so again so so so so so let's see so
uh again just to be honest with a
receiver what it means is that uh that
the the protocol allows it to to recover
BC but uh uh the view uh but not uh but
not the other one
um and the uh the goal of the
distinguisher that you know you wanted
to not be able to do is to uh is to
distinguish uh in the uh you know the
its view given uh uh you know B1 to c0
versus The View when the uh the other
bit is one so this is what you want to
be indistinguishable for the receiver
um and for the sender the same way what
you wanted is that the center will
distinguish between the case where C
equals zero and C plus one
um so uh so let's do uh EFI from
semi-announced Wheels transfer
um so we know the result that says that
we don't have a perfect statistical
oblivious transfer for most Center and
the receiver one of them has to break
right so let's assume that it breaks for
uh uh uh the sender there's no T there
so semi honest uh sender can break uh
inefficiently the protocol then uh what
do we do we have the following EFI from
that what are we the two distributions
so one distribution is going to be uh
the view of the sender the center not
going to put you know you know uh uh uh
two pluses you know in the higher mode
um
uh um
space or bases
into the OT and it's going to be going
to check the view of the sender when uh
the receiver has been zero and the other
one will be the same thing when the
receiver is this one right so uh so now
what we know is that there's got to be
indistinguishable because it's
computationally uh uh secure simion
security and uh it's going to be
specifically far because uh and a
inefficient cylinder can break right so
that's uh going to be one side uh so
assuming of the the sender cannot break
for this particular protocol so uh the
similar argument would be would be oops
same thing except that now the two
states are going to be depending on the
differences than the output the view of
the receiver and the difference is going
to be whether the the standard gave zero
or what
[Music]
um
so so again indistinguishability because
of because of the indistinguishability
of delt and sensitive distance because
the the receiver
so this is easy
um so now it's certainly less trivial
part but not so hard it also how to get
now with semi honest I believe it's
transfer from commitment which is little
statistic real statistically binding or
statistically highly so well we know how
to get a commitment or business
commitment for many years we did but all
those constructions used statistically
binding commitments but we don't have
that and you know so be sure to do it
you know but all we need is some yellow
City from any commitment which is not
statistically binding in particular
um so
um so so let's just do it
um so in fact let's as a warm-up let's
talk about one round you know honestly
responsive that's semi honest honest
only works when everybody is really
honest so what would be this obvious
transfer well I'm going to send the uh
the two bits uh one of them in the
standard basis the other one in the
height of our basis
um and then uh and then the receiver
yeah uh if c0 measures both bits uh in
the standard basis in in the you know if
this is one measures both in the
hardware basis and then it just it gets
to bits and the outputs you know the
right bit right
the other one is not available
um but and that's it so the security is
is is true is is is is uh triggered
because the other bit is just random but
what happens if this the receiver is on
semi honest and doesn't measure the
other bits right and then that's uh
that's that that's uh that's uh uh
that's a problem right because it's
purified can be uncomputed uh uh and we
can get uh you know
garbage from this
um so so in particular we cannot use it
later on to do our EFI so um so what are
we going to do we're going to force the
semi honest receiver to uh essentially
to measure how do we force it to measure
so one idea is that we just asked the
the receiver to send the you know the
other bit uh back to the uh to the
center right and you know as we know
sending parsing from the bit physically
is is the same thing as as measuring uh
but this is not good of course because
the receiver can see this bit it's still
going to be you know the the C is not
going to be hidden anymore
um so so instead what we're gonna do we
then actually ask the guy to send
commitments to uh uh uh to the bits to
the other to the other side commitment
to the two bits right
um and and now because it's highly
information at the idea the uh the other
I cannot see what those bits are
um but is sending a commitment to
something has the same effect of uh of
kind of effectively measuring as selling
the bit so if the commitment is
statistically binding then it's possible
that it is
um okay so so I'm going to get ahead of
myself so this is the this is the uh the
protocol now the setting the the
commitments a bit
um so uh
so now but but what is the what is the
issue here right so if the commitments
were statistically binding then would be
you know easy to see that you know you
can actually they're actually amounts to
uh uh to uh to measuring from the point
of view of the receiver uh but the point
is that even
with the the commitments could
potentially buying for only
computationally binding this is still
the case I'm gonna I'm not gonna you
know get details of sharing it but it's
something that was shown essentially in
uh Bayan
um what do some details that we had
um so anyway so this is so this is it so
we actually have EFI from a commitment
which is near statistics
um so so what are the address of the
results just to say it more more uh
completely so
um so give me statistically uh uh
statistically uh um binary commitments
uh we can you know we should be in below
already you know how to evaluate any
multi-party uh function uh with full
Security even even uh reactive
functionalities
um and even Quantum functionalities when
the inputs and the outputs are quantum
and even though they are the active so
uh so this is pretty strong and you'll
see the minute we'll use it
um and uh
um and then we could go the other way
essentially we can take the classical
results you know the binary results uh
uh about non-trivial multi-party
computation we show that any
functionality
uh that uh is there any natural
um NPC for that uh it implies I believe
it's right semi honest I believe it's
transfer and from that we get here
right so that uh uh so that's that's
that
um so any NPC Financial functionality
so what about zero nodes proofs so
one way to do it you know first let's
talk about uh qma
um so we can use standard your knowledge
with what commitment please commit an
open Paradigm uh that you know was shown
to uh that you can use it to do uh
um Quantum zero nodes even when the
witness is is a Quantum state but you
know but one downside of this that you
need the uh multiple copies of the
witness in order to do it you know but
you need to do application for
repetition every time you need a new
copy of the witness
instead what you can do you can actually
take a a
2pc functionality you know for the zero
knowledge functionality with Quantum
witness and it's basically statistical
security to the verified then you can
have to perceive a statistical security
for one of the sites uh uh thank you
um and uh and uh and now you can get uh
uh you know uh zero knowledge Quantum
reputation there are notes for
um any fall of Cuba it'll be just one
copy of the widgets right so so that's
that's nice
um so uh what about uh uh proof so all
qip right so so
we would like to uh to invoke the uh the
classics not just classical but also
classic zkp if that's all of the IP
right so if you remember what was
happening there you know so uh we took
you know there was an AM proof right uh
and then
um what the product was the very first
sense there is one of challenges and the
approval doesn't send the responses just
commitment to the responses and then in
the end it's give us one of those proof
that the original verify would have uh
uh been convinced
so how do we do expansively
um so it sounds like it's kind of a
problem right because you need a zero
note proofs now when the statements are
quantum because the second of the
commitments right so so it's not just
the the witness as the Quantum of the
statements are quantum now so how do you
do that it's not not so clear about how
to think about it you know how they will
agree what is the statement you know so
it's a one one day Quantum State uh uh
so what we do again again we do do the
NPC way so so now we have those uh The
Proven the verifier they're going to
jointly evaluate a Quantum reactive
functionality right so what is the
functionality is that the verify
provides the randomness and the approver
provides the the statement and then the
functionality interacts with the prover
uh you know in the in the archival way
using the randomness of the verify and
then in the end it runs the the MMA
verify player and am verify sorry and
and give the bit to to the original
paper and that's it
um so they usually we're thinking of you
know using zero Deutsche to the NPC in
the quantum world everything is standing
on its head as these two so we actually
use them to see to do their notes but
you know uh uh but now it should be no
surprise it's such a strange one uh so
anyway so
um and you can also get EF5 from the
unloads proofs right maybe you can
actually extend the idea of uh uh of uh
of uh ostrosity and because
so and you can actually uh you can get
uh
we can show that any uh Quantum uh uh
journalist proof for a language to give
you an instant dependent EFI uh based on
on the language and if the language is
you know hard on average then this
actually gives you a full-fledged GFI in
very much a similar way to uh towards
them classically again there are some
issues there because uh uh yeah you know
again there's this instance dependent
hashing universal one be hashing there
that that classically and here we cannot
do it because it's okay about these
things means you have to do it directly
but we do it never mind we don't have
time no but it can be done so anyway so
so this is a summary that what we had
before but the minimality
um and uh there's still a bunch of
things that are open that's not clear
but uh uh how they relate to EFI you
know the signatures one to money uh uh
um and uh i o have this relative effects
okay
um
so
another minute I had to talk about how
to obtain those guys so uh again when
we're going to talk about it uh but yeah
just one simple candidate right
um just you know choose uh uh you know a
random uh circuit uh but you know it's
random but once you choose it it's fixed
and you give it to the adversary say
maybe it's just about most circuits but
in my mind so anybody you choose a
random circuit you know it's a military
G and you know and then you just in one
of the side you just put a one here
itself exactly the one instead of a zero
it's here is your uh your EFI
you know
I don't know how to do it how to break
it and uh it's good question to think
about it and how we can uh
um think about how those things behave
it's not even clear to me classically if
you put things classical things here
whatever this would look like I don't
know but even be classically uh uh uh an
efid but that's what the player one
function locally
[Music]
there's no fan out if you're in a
Quantum circuit yeah that's true there's
no that's one thing there's nothing no
but here this outside the bedrooms right
so right so maybe that's a good answer
um yeah
but you know
it won't be actually nice to come up
with candidates and try to to break
because you know I don't have intuition
here right
um so uh yeah so and but these things
have been studied it's a random uh
Quantum circuits right so um maybe it
even realize a little bit of it so so
open problems right so these are
constructions uh amplification that we
discussed so you can amplify uh um yeah
gave some nice candidates right black
holes you know they can now we can have
the war law and black holes maybe black
will be smaller smaller in time to uh
you know you can have a black hole in
our pockets but uh yeah you know and um
are there any complexity buyers for the
existence of EFI and again I think no
one's going to talk about it
um and uh another question is there a
hierarchy is there can you uh have a
criminal yet so uh uh version of the
worlds right you know in quite the world
is it just one world I don't know
um and uh um and another question that
music again from the trigger stock is
you know maybe it's just a love nature
that t5s exists and you kind of like
shortcut uh random circuits uh in
physical reality who knows
um and uh
thank you
[Applause]
so
come on
[Applause]